seguramente estamos ante el inicio de
otro nuevo pulso del líder opositor
contra el cree ming los abogados están
preocupados por la salud de nava lee y
el ahora exige un médico el líder
opositor ruso ha declarado desde la
cárcel una huelga de hambre para
presionar a las autoridades de la
prisión para que le permitan que le
visite su médico personal naval y sufre
fuertes dolores en la espalda dice que
desde hace unos días no siente una de
sus piernas sin embargo fuentes de la
prisión aseguran que su estado es a
pesar de todo satisfactorio tiene por
delante dos años de condena
el opositor ruso cumple una pena de
prisión en la ciudad de poco croft en la
provincia de vladimir a unos 100
kilómetros al este de moscú el lugar es
famoso por el aislamiento que impone a
sus presos y también por las difíciles
condiciones de vida naval ni lo ha
considerado un campo de concentración
este lunes denunció que se exponía a ser
enviado a un confinamiento en solitario
después de ser apercibido por asuntos
menores como por ejemplo levantarse diez
minutos antes de la hora